[Musique]
et je viens d'avoir une info sachez que
maintenant on en est sûr
les téléspectateurs de tpm pecqueux
chaîne voilà je vous aime je vous adore
vous êtes ma passion et je sais
aujourd'hui que ce ne sont pas des
spécialistes de danse mais ce que sachez
qu'à l'heure qu'il est raymond est
toujours en tête et ça n'est pas une
bonne nouvelle dit à 18h57 je peux vous
le dire qu'il sait vraiment qui est
honteux de boxe à l'âge où il dit pas
que gilbert montagné caboter ou alors
cette vanne il a fait tous les jours
surtout voilà rôles mais c'est vrai
qu'il a fait tous les jours sur et vous
voilà il ya ben ali qui va arriver dans
un instant elle est en train de remettre
son slip bon je vais commencer avec un
terrible mensonge qui a été prononcée
lors d'une épreuve sportive qui sera aux
jo-2000 24 c'est quoi le jonglage de
balle avec ping pong sur une bouteille
de gels antibactériens
il y avait un concours vous soyez contre
les chroniqueurs qui bien sûr n'avaient
jamais pratiqué ce sport
moi j'ai jamais pratiqué vous avez
jamais pratiqué doucement avant ta
gueule dégâts non mais je me pose la
question vous a jamais porté les gars je
te jure un mois j'en ai assez de
gourcuff c'est que le début série le
monde et donc il nous le jour pendant
l'émission qui n'a jamais pratiqué c'est
vraiment dur et si si si avant ce fameux
30 janvier moi je vous croyais les yeux
fermés parce que vous n'êtes vous pas
trop où me payer donc je vous crois
toujours mais ces images comment envoyer
directement vont bouleverser les
français c'est pas ça du tout mais c'est
pas ça si c'est pas ça du tout y est
mais qu en régie vous en êtes où et
comment ça va d'accord merci on y
retourne attention le jonglage peut-être
attention aie appelle à une pied de
retour
[Musique]
donc le jeu des jongles avec un gel
antibactérien soit c'est très dur
soit c'est les chroniqueurs qui sont
très nul mais là n'était pas mal non
mais dites 2 alors une fois de plus
c'est que j'avais dû montrer vous étiez
le meilleur dans n'importe quel sport
moossmann ce qui n'existe pas c'est une
véritable leçon alors pourtant il paraît
que c'est la première fois de votre vie
vous pratiquer ce sport on est toujours
content d'eux pour l'épreuve de très
bons alors donc j'ai jamais fait les
chéris commis le 30 janvier vous
expliquez que jamais dans votre vie vous
n'aviez jongler avec du gel
antibactérien pourtant le 23 janvier
qu'est ce que vous faisiez pendant la
pub
les faits
alors j'avais fait parce que quand il
avait fait là c'est avec la tête et le
truc j'avais pas fais avec la jolie
yvelines journée johnny en pis pour
m'annoncer pas molli cas d'ailleurs
demain j'ai envie de relancer les
ballons 4-0 voiture à je sais quoi vous
allez choisir le jeu d'accord voilà vous
choisirez l'épreuve à laquelle vous de
me battre avec toi on sait que ce ne
sera pas le ouvrez l'oeil
nombre d'intellectuels dont vous n'êtes
pas là demain
[Rires]
on a vu hier les coups de pression de
jean michel mr a serré la main mais sa
vraie spécialité outre chine et les
nouvelles chroniqueuses préparez-vous
fanny ça reste de fayoter auprès de vous
sarr elle adore c'est le retour du terme
par le maillot alors on va penser que
parce que j'adore vous allez voir
jean-michel littéralement subjugué par
une de vos danses l'admiration des bords
de ses yeux aujourd'hui je suis subjugué
par toi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
arrêtez-moi compétition quand vous êtes
jeunes on a des gens qui peuvent tenir
sur les lèvres des lévriers février
cyril est un animal ce serait ça serait
quoi bon moi c'est une fait penser à un
suricate hockey à des pressions à la
salle de sport avant pour draguer mais
pour faire un pas nouveau
alors que j'allais aimer shamir vient
d'arriver à les gens n'osent pas quand
la personne est trop beau les gens
n'osent pas s'approcher sait même pas si
c'est vrai faut dire ce qui est les gens
nous fait peur aux gens
on est en 2020 c'est bon quoi on n'a
plus envie de ça on a envie de gens
sympa j'aime pas ta gueule pas dire
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
5 0
c'est magnifique garder le produit c'est
la joie de vivre incarnée jours
franchement c'est dingue quand on est
c'est dingue parce que on se dit non et
pourtant si tout cela vous arrive
confort des clients mais le gars il voit
50% des choses et il est heureux sans
brad va très bien je l'espère oui la
semaine prochaine savais que je vais
faire un tour de tennis je vais le coach
et je vais le coach je vais le coach et
je peux vous dire il va aller très très
loin
ouais bah maintenant il faut qu'ils
juste qu'il arrive à voir les balles de
tennis qui venait de vivre le soldat gay
sur un terrain tennis ou à des balles de
ping-pong bbb tu sais que je t'aime toi
que je sais et il m'envoie des textos
tous les matins je voulais le dire non à
tous les matins à oui ce matin c'était
très drôle que j'envoyais vraie annonce
une méthode de relaxation que j'ai mise
en vente il ya récemment et qui fait un
carton dans toutes les mairies c'est la
méthode
j'avais pas vu leurs yeux celle là elle
consiste que pour votre corps et votre
esprit en fait que ça sente mieux à
balancer tout ce que vous pensez des
autres exactement vous allez voir avec
une particularité en mettent plein la
gueule à tout le monde
le créateur de cette méthode c'est vous
cyril et j'ai quelques exemples pour
essayer la méthode baba scène
[Musique]
quand cyril hanouna donne son avis sur
l'émission deux heures de rires et de
direct c'est un parfait exemple de
maîtrise de soi
il produisait cette meilleure perdure on
a pas compétition mais je crois que vous
aussi vous ne l'avez pas compris une
purge parler des émissions de france 2
permettent à cyril hanouna d'inspirer
profondément puis d'expirer tout le bien
qu'il pense du service public dans la
commander 2 oui bah c'est sur france
télé c'est vrai c'est pour ça qu'on les
aime quand ça marche par mois pour fait
l'audience comme des missions vous
faisiez vendredi et samedi sur france 2
en prime time en divertissement offert
le dimanche si tu t'es pas ouvert une
vanne ou deux frères t c tpat et solide
mon frère c'est un mental d'acier quoi
regarder la tête de julien combes et ça
se sent qu'il sera bientôt adepte de la
méthode de base n voilà après il ya
d'autres programmes il ya ya ya the
voice mais c est ça y est c'est julien
courbet qui pourra regarder samedi soir
sur france 2 il n'y a rien comme d'hab
et sur trois là aussi quand le comité
olympique interdite atp mp d'utiliser le
terme olympiades sans payer une fortune
cyril hanouna parviennent à un contrôle
total
en ouvrant tous ses chakras une très
forte somme mais aujourd'hui ça
s'appelle les babas l'implosion et pris
l'or
[Musique]
les anneaux olympiques symbolisent les
cinq continents savez pourquoi ya cinq
anneaux tact à quoi d'autres qui
arrivent alors il ya quelque chose à
quelqu'un autour de la table qui est
philosophe et je m'attendais pas du tout
à ce que cette personne soit aussi
cultivé mois pour na vi et kelly non non
ces sites et matthieu delormeau mathieu
de la cultiver
ouais j'aurais la philo selon mathieu
non il est cultivé c'est-à-dire dans un
jardin s'est relevé dans un jardin ou ce
que vous allez moi philo selon mathieu
ont agréé de lactation va se retrouver
dans un instant les cherry pour la suite
de tpm paix où on cédric it a encore des
choses à nous montrer effectivement
matthieu delormeau je disais tout à
l'heure n'est pas qu'un corps de culture
et c'est aussi un cerveau de cultiver
ses relais que depuis ou font penser
qu'il pouvait seulement citer toutes les
sortes de caniches dans le monde mais il
peut aussi citer les grands philosophes
mais oui plus grands philosophes
alors pour faire le gars érudit en fait
il a pris quelques phrases de trois ans
auteur il essore des qui peut mais bon
ces phrases ce sont les arbres qui
cachent la forêt amazonienne
la philo selon mathieu
[Musique]
matthieu delormeau on a l'impression
qu'en 18 ans d'école nalu console
auteurs
mais lors des séries la poète aimait ou
quittez pas bon ça met plus en plus tôt
on part toujours trop tard paul edwards
quelquefois matthieu delormeau site
dépenses et de certains actes isabelle
morini bosc
l'accès ce n'est jamais un hasard
malraux exactement merci un échec aussi
[Rires]
pour moi les mots de raymond devos à
bonn humoriste ce sont des textes un
très bon humoriste c'est un univers qui
attend un enfant des grands auteurs
moitié de leur montrer lui-même ses
propres pensées mais cette fois on est
plus proche d'un grand philosophe belge
jean claude van damme
on va tous cas c'est des trucs voilà
merci alors quatre enfants s'est jeté
sur son enfance pickas l'enfant qui veut
faire en toi et tu exprimes l'adulte qui
est en train de venir celui que tu es
toi tout cas tu as fait blanche et tout
[Applaudissements]
était clair et on écoute donc la stilo
selon mathieu mais bon on n'est pas
encore prêt de voir la langue française
selon mathieu la preuve
parfois le rythme était très non des
prêts nenê dans l'émission grecque va
devoir les audiences décollement mais
mes fans français international vous le
savez il a des relents d'énergie
[Musique]
moi j'aime bien bien vague aux
vérifications on apprend des choses et
ça fait du bien d'apprendre des choses
un petit peu dans ce monde quoi manche
andy marte on reconnaissait quand je
suis pas là ça manque un peu de culture
non merci ça manque peut-être de culture
mais ça manque pas d'audience pour le
record d'hier soir bercy l'appellation
il était la matière non non non on se
dit bonjour
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je rappelle que demain ce sera le tabac
bat donc c'est parfait
ce soit la vie de battre mais non
m'arrête quoi ça marche ce côté là ça
marche quand t'es pas là ça marche ça va
et plus ça va c'est encore mieux quand
et là oui non oui
l'audience n'est jamais un hasard paul
eluard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
non à l'épaule anwar les aider à les
imposer ça tout va bien la vie est belle
c'est fort merci alors le mercredi c'est
que je finis toujours ma chronique avec
des images de la révolte des
chroniqueurs contre le patronat
quand les chroniqueurs se lâche sur 6 à
la glace ça s'appelle le tard backlash
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
neymar 3 millions d'euros par mois
moi aussi qu'on puisse comparer vous
situez où vous bien de faire chier avec
plaisir ma vie a dormi de france je sais
mais voit avec plaisir jeter un oeil aux
super roi george takei hamelin quant à
trente pièces s'est facilement
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ça serait allé même pas le croiser chez
vous car si j'ai loupé rodez castaldi tu
t'aime toi je m'adore non franchement
non je mets beaucoup quand et regard est
de plus en plus je fais comme vous j'ai
j'applique la méthode des anneaux n'a
jamais regardé du teint tout est là moi
je fais ça moi tous les jours la loge
excusez moi je fais ça m'a aidé et
festif et contempler la beauté et la
deuxième avec d'autres c'est qu'il est
tout le temps dans un dos d'âne comme
vous connaissez bien dans un hôtel près
de cap d'antibes qui est un hôtel très
très cher aux dit je connais très bien
la mosquée babri ce qui est très cher et
donc c'est quoi ces 6 h 6 non je te
parle du tableau de mendeleïev
périodique des éléments
[Musique]
là
[Applaudissements]